welcome to this video of the round 11
game of the candidates tournament
between under Aiken and Mammadyarov yeah
to sum up the player standings before
this game dragon on minus one not much
of a chance to still catch up to Anand
mamedyarov on fifty percent hmm yeah
it's still a long way from overtaking
her first place but okay you need to at
least them try to figure out ideas how
how island could could be catched
otherwise Colonel Thierry boring but
yeah mamedyarov I mean he needs to win
basically to get the slight chance but
it is very very slight admittedly let's
see what they did in the game I'm
breaking playing 93 yeah he plays all
opening moves so we cannot really tell
about a surprise or anything yeah we got
a queen's gambit declined at first but
ok it's going to be a catalan um yeah
should Mammadyarov have played something
a bit sharper yeah well i don't know he
went for this and here played removes
five which is some quite um yeah how to
classify the move it's hard to tell
sometimes you have you can attach
something labeled two moves like oh this
is very boring this is very solid this
is very sharp cannot really do that to
c5 it's sort of a middle-of-the-road
move um especially it's allowing one or
two lines that are really a bit bit dull
um if you really want to do to fight
like i don't know to fight for for a
witness black once you enter this year
you could argue for the move like be
five which is very risky of course but
you could argue that for the black
player only wind counts in a way okay
but he played he played c5 he played see
five castles 96 and here we come to the
point where where I am
said that white can play a line after
which it is very dull and this is what
Andre conditi took on c5 um darlin
disrespect us maybe a bit disrespectful
it's not it's not a bad move at all but
it's it's it's more interesting of
course here for why to play a playa
gambit in the gambit star like 95 for
example which is that's actually the
line that I play myself in this position
where now when I reach it the idea is
that this is a very direct mistake still
happens in and blitz games quite often
check okay people simply if they don't
know the line that's it it seems like
you three years are a tricky move to to
spot okay this is not the real idea of
course the idea is that why the
threatening here so Bishop d7 and then
something like that assume the the
follow-up wear white has very nice
pieces in the center and still this good
bishop this is a fine or an okay line
for black camp but it's a bit more
complicated then he takes d5 okay the
idea is that what what why it is doing
is that you will get this porn back and
black he has actually forced to play the
C 3 move 40 played in the game if black
is not doing that let's say castles yeah
then why takes and has an excellent
position it's simply a simple that is
right we'll get to e5 and we'll play
with a good bishop on g2 for no
particular compensation like side this
is why black abandons the porn with c3
to worsen the pawn structure something
similar happened today also in the in
the chrome neck on art game castles
might be three you should be seven and
see for all this looks very normal and
we have a struggle in this position
between why it's very good position
pieces of our position pieces like the
and white has the slide structural
damage on the on the queenside this is
blacks compensation for the fact that he
is not so actively placed with the
bishop and has some space a disadvantage
the next couple of moves are very
logical and have been played before we
should be to route 28 night to deform
and look to see a tall this looks so
normal that I really don't want to
elaborate very low on that night to be
five yeah this is introducing ideas
maybe to capture take a take on a seven
and he'll be six was played yeah what
happens if white captures now the
problem is the route capture that a taxi
for immediately so it's not a good idea
drinking played rook see one yeah it's
not a terribly exciting position I must
admit and a five now played by
Mammadyarov yeah at some point you need
to take care of the a porn and this is
what he did here it looks a bit
weakening okay but it also has active
ideas like a form and maybe 95 so let's
say white white now plays a for himself
him and the dragon was already spending
huge amounts of time it's really a
remarkable that you very often does not
I mean it's just speculating does not
know the lines and finds it all over the
board I'm it's been really possible this
has happened quite a number of times in
this tournament that yet spend lots of
time and the opponent was basically just
playing the preparation and he always
took a couple of minutes for all the
theoretical moves yeah a form if you
don't do that let's say white plays a
nothing move then black goes a form and
Knight a5 and this you don't really want
to have c4 gets weak so a for it's
probably a move you need to play and now
Bishop be a
bye Mammadyarov yeah no one breaking
took on the 8th and believe it or not we
are still in a position that had been
played before you know I think I found a
game you dealt chef very strong
Bulgarian Grandmaster against Lana
swatted Oh Spanish player quite good
play almost 2500 rated last year on the
spanish player took on d8 with the night
and this in fact after c5 takes night x
led to position that is somewhat
favorable for white the a porn is a
factor and you will get the night nicely
back to see form no black does not have
many active possibilities he lost this
game and in the end and it's not not
much fun to play remember dro forever
took with the rook and this seems to be
the more precise decision we see that
play is getting quite quite similar to
the to the mansion game um yeah what
happens now if he s c5 is played just
like in this mansion game yeah one point
is that if we look at this straight
there is a new look do you want it and
this looks really uncomfortable 92 or
threatened and after Luke c1 probably
necessary at the end Black gets good
play against the upon this will probably
still end in a draw but it's simply
nothing to play for so c5 is no move he
played age 3 this is directed against
this rookie one resource with check with
we should have one necessary now you get
a flight square on h2 yeah night before
wasn't late now and this is again
directed against c5 which was played
anyway but the thing is if white is not
going 45 and
fix this a structural problem then
long-term this might be an issue if you
consider let's say white place place non
non forcing moves that do nothing I'll
just put it on the board you can easily
imagine a position where I know this
doesn't make any sense the white mousse
wear black young can get the night to
see five on alternatively you can also
use this night if you can firmly
blockade on c5 especially with a night
then a four and ce4 become long-term
problems so why basically needs to play
c5 in this position which you did and
the bad news for The Spectator is if you
look at this black needs to take and
white will take on a five now yeah now
we have a position where this is a week
pawn and this is a recon and the next
couple of moves are completely a
completely logical and simply look at
this reduce the complete queenside to
nothing yeah now the only thing is white
has got two bishops but but that's it
really a couple of moves later we also
got looks traded and we came to this end
game which is certainly certainly nice
with two two bishops but there is really
not much going on with all pawns being
on one side of the board and black
having no structural weakness um this
this could be motley interesting if
black would have some sort of double
porn or yeah it did I mean not even a
double porn but would make it
interesting let's say the g7 4mon h6 or
something without being able to capture
it I mean serious weakness but it's not
it's simply not on the board it's just a
perfectly sound position yeah and
I won't do anything in terms of
commentary on this moves they they try
it for a bit of course but I mean under
a contrite blacker can do absolutely
zilch air yeah they they actually had
this this this end of the game Bishop
takes c6 and this counter sacrifice okay
well there is simply simply nothing
going on at the end we have this
position which is obviously completely
dead like just puts a king on g7 and
then move the night to wherever and the
Jeep one is never going anywhere yeah
this is a was in fact at the end a
really boring game but it is sometimes
happening out of just logically out of
the structure which oops this was too
much sorry yeah this the slide actually
has a reputation of being slightly
better for white but it simply didn't
materialize it seems that black played a
very solid set up here and right here is
just as I said if why does not play c5
he will stand worse and c5 just leads to
the complete clearance of the Queen side
at the end and not much to be done um
yeah well is someone should mother Maria
of played a bit sharper I mean as I
mentioned her at the beginning of the
video you can always tell nice stories
after you know that the game is ending
in a very in a very boring draw but yeah
maybe he's just saying okay I'm playing
a good moves and see what happens this
is maybe a good good way to go about it
I mean after all catching aren't being
one and a half points down with four
games to go is almost impossible
anywhere you need some help from from
Alan basically maybe a blunder something
but it's not looking like that okay so
at the end not too not too exciting game
here I hope you enjoyed the brief
coverage anyway thanks for
gene